okay everybody here are some scientific
method scenarios i'd like you to explore
feel free to use your class notes as you
go through these problems here we go
scenario number one 50 runners volunteer
to test a new sports drink that promises
to hydrate better than water
volunteers are asked to run 20 miles
while hydrating with water a week later
they return to run another 20 miles
hydrating with the sports drink the time
taken to complete the runs are recorded
answer the four questions
all right for part a what is the control
group or the control group again what's
the normal condition in this case
hydrating with water is the normal
condition
the experimental group is what's being
manipulated what's different and in this
case runners when drinking the sports
drink
letter c the independent variable again
an independent variable is what's
different between the two test groups
here well one's drinking water and one's
drinking sports drink so the difference
is the type of beverage
and then part d
the dependent variable the dependent
variable is what data is being collected
in this case the data being collected is
the time taken to complete the runs
let's try another scenario
okay scenario number two does increased
protein in our diet aid our ability to
solve problems 100 people are affected
traditional healthy meals over the
course of one month
another group of 100 people are fed
healthy meals with double the amounts of
protein for one month
after one month both groups of people
are tested to solve reasoning and logic
puzzles
answer the four questions
so question a what is the control group
again a control group is what is the
normal conditions in this case it's the
people that are fed to traditional meals
part b what is the manipulated or the
experimented experimental group what's
manipulated is that the the hundred
people are fed double the amount of
protein
part c the independent variable again
independent variables how do these two
groups differ well one's fed traditional
meals and one is fed meals with double
the amount of protein so the independent
variable is the type of food the type of
meals that they are provided
and then part d the dependent variable
the dependent variable the data being
measured what are we measuring is their
ability to solve these logic and
reasoning puzzles
here's another scenario
while plants grow better when exposed to
classical music both area a and area b
are filled with seeds the seeds in both
areas are equally watered and have
access to equal amounts of sunlight both
areas are kept at the same temperature
the only difference is the seeds of area
a are exposed to classical music while
area b is kept silent
after one season
the plants of area a averaged 20 percent
extra growth
answer the four questions
okay part a what is the control group i
hope you said that's the area the plants
of area b those not exposed to music
part b what is the experimental group
again those are the plants of area a the
plants that were exposed to music
part c what is the independent variable
how do these two groups differ well
one's given music and one isn't
so the independent variable is the
exposure or the presence of music
part d
the dependent variable again that's the
data being measured in this case is the
amount of growth i hope you found this
review to be helpful i will talk about
this in class